[Musik]
warteschlangen vor vielen läden und
immer mehr leere stühle in den schulen
deutschland steuert auf den shutdown zu
nadelstich vor laufenden kameras in den
usa soll der start von impfungen den
menschen wieder hoffnung geben und
hammer gegner in der champions league
auf deutsche vereine kommen mit
liverpool oder manchester city harte
brocken zu
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nationalen in
einer neuen nachrichten woche kristin
otto ist hier bei mir für den sport
heute in der sendung sehr gern hallo und
guten abend
es wird eine woche die im gedächtnis
bleibt der bundespräsident sagt heute ab
mittwoch wird unser leben so stark
eingeschränkt wie noch nie in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik bitter
ernst sei die lage
frank walter steinmeier spricht von
einer zitat prüfung für uns alle
wir werden weihnachten und neujahr
anders feiern als wir gehofft hatten
die kommenden wochen werden wir viele
menschen eine belastende zeit seien die
einschränkungen die wir uns auf ihr
legen müssen gefährden wirtschaftliche
existenzen
sie machen einsam und sie drücken aufs
gemüt
ich bin ganz sicher die pandemie wird
uns die zukunft nicht rauben
wir werden diese krise überwinden
das muss gelingen und es wird gelingen
sagt der bundespräsident wir berichteten
ausführlich in dieser sendung und
beginnen jetzt mit der situation in
deutschlands einkaufsstraßen
morgen geht noch dann ist schluss mit
der weihnachts mit dem weihnachts
shopping in der innenstadt schluss auch
mit einem sehr wichtigen geschäft für
den handel heute gab es an manchen orten
nochmal warteschlangen und einiges an
trubel was natürlich einen last minute
geschenke suchen liegt und andererseits
natürlich alles andere als nützlich ist
bei der bekämpfung einer pandemie zu
entrichten hat mir vor diesem hamburger
einkaufszentrum war es am nachmittag so
weit zu viele kunden für zu wenig platz
dem center blieb nichts anderes übrig
als die türen zu schließen die kunden
blieben hanseatisch gelassen
bereits am morgen herrschte
schlussverkaufs stimmung in der
innenstadt der einzelhandel erwartet
fiel
zwei tage nur noch für das
weihnachtsgeschäft die ersten standen
eine stunde vor ladenöffnung bereit um
möglichst schnell alles
zu erledigen dabei gibt es keine
sonderangebote sondern nur das gefühl
dass weihnachten schon mit vor der
ladentür steht im grunde hätten dir
gleich ab heute machen müssen so nach
dem motto sagt lock down und es gibt gar
nichts mehr
allerdings bin ich schon froh drum weil
ich muss leider gottes auch noch was
besorgen meine die leute die jetzt um
fünf vor zwölf das wachwerden für dieses
natürlich ärgerlich ich finde es ein
bisschen albern diese schließung
irgendwie mit mit zwei tage anlauf also
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
leute sicher davon abhalten lassen jetzt
nochmal komplett irgendwie den ankauf zu
starten
trotzdem haben die ersten geschäfte
bereits die öffnungszeiten ausgeweitet
und so schließt das alsterhaus heute und
morgen erst um 22 uhr am späten
nachmittag waren die einkaufsstraßen in
hamburg allerdings nicht so voll dass es
dem einzelhandel viel hilft es hat die
letzten tage schon nichts gebracht und
wenn mich jetzt durch die stadt gehen
merken wir aber solch eine ganz schwache
frequenz dass wir da kriegt natürlich
ein wenig dazu bei der drops ist
gelutscht wird nichts mehr passieren und
wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich
runterfahren
dieses mal gilt das auch für die
baumärkte entsprechend waren bei manchen
geschäften die parkplätze bereits um
kurz nach acht uhr heute morgen voll
tannenbäume dürfen die händler weiterhin
verkaufen allerdings nur in solchen
draußen geschäften eine chance für
kleine händler
für so manchen lohnen aber auch diese
beiden letzten verkaufstage nicht für
alle anderen beginnt der winterschlaf am
mittwoch der schotter und des
weihnachtsgeschäfts bedeutet jetzt noch
mehr online bestellungen als ohnehin
schon dieses jahr bei den paketzusteller
firmen die sich 1,6 milliarden pakete
hat allein die deutsche post in diesem
jahr bis ende november ausgeliefert dass
es mehr als im gesamten letzten jahr und
jetzt kurz vorm fest rechnen viele mit
einer bestellung wiener julia schröter
wer seinen liebsten ein weihnachtspaket
schicken will der braucht viel geduld
nicht nur hier an der hauptpost in mainz
an poststellen quer durch die republik
heißt es gerade anstehen verletzten tage
war die schlange auf teilweise so lange
jetzt bisschen mehr und muss als lenker
war aber
ich habe mich darauf eingestellt dass
die schon relativ lange frankfurt geht
das für eine freundin und
weihnachtskarten weihnachten nur im
kleinen kreis dazu die aufforderung
möglichst nicht zu reisen weil die
weihnachtsgabe aber doch zum beschenkten
muss und zusätzlich immer mehr menschen
online bestellen hat die post in diesem
jahr rekord mengen zu transportieren
an einem normalen tag bearbeiten die
post zentren im schnitt 5,2 millionen
sendungen jetzt sind es an spitzentagen
mehr als doppelt so viel
11 millionen damit trotzdem alles
pünktlich ankommt red die post
spätestens bis zum 19 12 uhr mittags
also samstag alle pakete abzuschicken
doch nicht nur die geschenke haben viele
vor dem erneuten shutter und im blick
sondern auch den eigenen anblick
friseure erleben gerade einen
regelrechten ansturm
es ist natürlich so dass ganz viele
kunden noch wollen und das telefon
ständig klingelt und wir
ich habe mir jetzt auch niemanden mehr
rein kriegen weil es wirklich ich
arbeite heute abend bis 22 uhr am morgen
auch bis 22 uhr von morgens um acht also
es ist schon wahnsinn
den wunsch sich noch mal die haare schön
machen zu lassen haben viele erfüllen
wird er sich für die wenigsten bis zum
nächsten haarschnitt könnte es dauern
denn keiner weiß wie es nach dem zehnten
januar weitergeht
ebenfalls schließen müssen die schulen
und kitas und da stellt sich die frage
für viele familien
wer auf die kinder aufpasst für
berufstätige eltern die zur betreuung
daheim bleiben müssen verspricht der
bund eine entschädigung was all das für
eltern lehrerinnen und erzieher bedeutet
zeigt nicola albrecht das sind die
fahrräder der zehntklässler und
abiturienten der katholischen
marienschule in potsdam
denn nur sie haben neben den
grundschülern in dieser woche noch
unterricht in der schule alle anderen
schüler sind zu hause denn die
präsenzpflicht ist in brandenburg
bereits ab heute ausgesetzt so nennt es
die landesregierung offiziell
ziemlich schwammig und mit anderen
worten die verantwortung für die
umsetzung liegt bei schulen und eltern
beate meißner unterrichtet ihre neunte
klasse nun wieder per video-konferenz ja
uns tut es sehr für die schüler leid
weil sie wirklich sehr froh waren die
anderen hier zu treffen
und natürlich ist der direkte kontakt zu
schülern einfach
sehr wichtig sowohl für die schüler als
auch für die lehrer aber was technische
angeht sind wir eigentlich inzwischen
routiniert an vielen staatlichen schulen
sieht das allerdings ganz anders aus
hier in frankfurt oder fürchten sich die
schüler schon seit wochen vor diesem
erneuten shutdown
denn für unterricht per video fehlt die
ausstattung als die schule im frühjahr
geschlossen war kamen die aufgaben per e
mail
mehr kontakt zu lehrern und mitschülern
gab es nicht tanzunterricht war sehr
schwierig ich bin in die schule gekommen
dann nach innen des trans unterricht und
mittlerweile stehen heute fünf aus dem
digital pakt steht eigentlich geld zur
technischen ausstattung der schulen zur
verfügung doch vielerorts scheitert es
wie hier an der umsetzung
das geld ist angekommen und jetzt suchen
wir firmen die diese arbeiten erledigen
können digitale ausstattung ist in kitas
nicht die debatte hier geht es
ausschließlich um präsenz notbetreuung
in sachsen bereits ab heute nur für
eltern in systemrelevanten berufen alle
anderen müssen sich selbst um ihre
kinder kümmern
wir nehmen schon hohen druck bei der
elternschaft und was glaube ich dieses
mal hinzukommt ist die erfahrung und das
erleben aus dem ersten lockdown das home
office und kinder zu hause zu betreuen
vielleicht noch verschiedene
altersgruppen eine unheimliche
herausforderung ist verständnis dafür
bei denen die sich helfen können
die situation ist so dass wir uns
einfach organisiert aufteilen meine
frauen dich um die arbeitgeber machen
das mit was gut ist
schulleiter thomas rathmann aus potsdam
wünscht sich nun vor allem eins wirklich
eindeutige ansagen aus der politik damit
sich alle darauf einstellen können wie
es nach den weihnachtsferien weitergehen
soll
und da gucken wir jetzt auf den
politischen aspekt des ganzen dass die
bevölkerung vertrauen in politisches
handeln hat das ist ja das a und o in
einer pandemie theorie jetzt stellt sich
allerdings aktuell zudem die frage wie
viel vertrauen die handelnden politiker
selbst noch in ihrer
entscheidungsgrundlagen haben denn da
müssen sich einige jetzt doch selbst
korrigieren
in der tat ich erinnere beispielsweise
an folgenden satz des
bundesgesundheitsministers gesagt am
ersten september zitat mit dem wissen
heute müssen keine friseure mehr
schließen und kein einzelhandel mehr
schließen das wird nicht noch mal
passieren
zitat ende ab mittwoch passiert es
dennoch und jens spahn hat den satz eben
auch als fehleinschätzung eingeräumt die
politik ist jetzt offensichtlich in
einer neuen phase des pandemie realismus
und der besagt es muss noch mehr getan
werden noch mehr dicht gemacht werden
allerdings sind weder friseure noch
leben bekannte hotspots der ansteckung
aber auch sie erzeugen natürlich
kontakte durch den weg zum einkauf mit
bus und bahn durch den gang ins volle
einkaufszentrum und damit werden sie im
sinne der gleichbehandlung quasi zu
mitgefangenen der weitgehenden kontakt
reduzierung des politische fahren auf
sicht das im moment erleben heißt also
jetzt für viel mehr betroffene
stillstand theo koll hat sich dann für
diese einschätzung live aus berlin
und hier sind die gemeldeten positiven
testergebnisse deren zahl ist wieder
gestiegen im wochenvergleich das robert
koch institut meldet 16 1362
neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden
das sind 4 1030 mehr als vergangenen
montag 188 menschen sind an oder mit dem
virus gestorben besuch nicht nur an den
weihnachtsfeiertagen ist besonders
wichtig für die menschen den alten und
pflegeheimen
gleichzeitig ist aber dort auch das
corona risiko am größten
seit monaten geht es darum gerade die
verwundbarsten besser zu schützen
passiert ist wenig kritiker sehen darin
das vielleicht größte versäumnis bei der
korona bekämpfung
ab mittwoch soll es verpflichtend tests
geben für bewohner personal und besucher
und gleichzeitig bleiben große zweifel
ob das jetzt gelingt dominik müller sl
mit einem beispiel aus köln es war ein
kraftakt aber sie haben es hinbekommen
im caritas-haus an sankt georg in köln
einmal die woche ein schnelltest für
jeden bewohner alle pflegekräfte und
regelmäßig auch für angehört
die zu besuch kommen doch bewohner und
pflegepersonal mehrmals die woche testen
und jeden besucher ist beim besten
willen nicht zu schaffen sagen sie wir
müssen jeden tag jeden besucher testen
der reinkommt also wenn das noch einmal
verschärft werden sollte oder auch wenn
es nur so wird dass wir sagen wir müssen
vier mal in der woche termine anbieten
zur testung und am wochenende dann ist
das mit dem personal was zurzeit im
altenheim ist nicht zu schaffen
an den tests mangelt es gar nicht aber
wie er soll sie eben durchführen wenn
schon jetzt an allen ecken und enden
pflegerinnen und pfleger vielen
patientenschützer befürchten dass eine
gut gemeinte regelung für die
bewohnerinnen und bewohner letztlich
nichts gutes heißt gerade an den
feiertag also wenn die angehörigen nicht
am einlass des pflegeheim getestet
werden können dann müssen sie sich
irgendwo her diesen schnell test holen
und das wird praktisch unmöglich sein
eine schnellste station aufzügen dann
unverzüglich in ein pflegeheim zu kommen
praktisch ist das ein besuchsverbot
woher also personal für die schnelltests
nehmen wenn kannst da ist die betreiber
der alten und pflegeheime fordern
dringend unterstützung von
hilfsorganisationen wie rotem kreuz
malteser johanniter wenn man das hier
annähernd täglich über etliche stunden
anbieten soll
brauchen wir also leute die zu uns
kommen verlässlich zu uns kommen und in
einem zeitkorridor diese tests
verlässlich anbieten
dann können wir natürlich eine solche
schlagzahl deutlich erhöhen und auch das
sicherheitsniveau damit erhöhen wenn das
schon zu weihnachten gelänge die
menschen in den heimen wären froh
kostenlose ffp zwei schutzmasken für
risikogruppen das hatte die
bundesregierung versprochen
ab morgen soll das funktionieren sagte
das bundesgesundheitsministerium für
über 60-jährige und menschen mit
vorerkrankungen drei stück abzuholen in
den apotheken deutschland fährt runter
dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial gleich hier
nach uns und in der zdf- heute- app ein
überblick über die geschäfte die trotz
satter und hoffen bleiben vom waschsalon
bis zum weihnachtsbaumverkauf die
zulassung für den corona impfstoff in
der europäischen union wird
schnellstmöglich erfolgen ist aber kaum
zu beschleunigen so sagt dass die chefin
der europäischen arzneimittelbehörde und
reagiert damit auf druck den unter
anderem gesundheitsminister jens spahn
am wochenende gemacht hatte
großbritannien hat bereits vergangene
woche mit massen impfungen begonnen
heute ziehen kanada und die usa nach
allein die verteilung des serums dort
ist eine gewaltige logistik aktion peter
theißen
sie ist die erste die vor laufenden
kameras live im amerikanischen fernsehen
die impfung bekommt zentralen say eine
krankenschwester aus new york ich möchte
öffentlich vertrauen schaffen dass die
impfung sicher ist wir erleben eine
pandemie und wir müssen alle unseren
teil dazu beitragen diese pandemie zu
stoppen
präsident trump reagierte prompt erste
impfung verabreicht glückwunsch usa
glückwunsch welt er nimmt die forderung
zurück dass zuerst die mitarbeiter im
weißen haus geimpft werden sollten wo es
bis zuletzt empfänge gab ohne abstand
zuerst kommt nun das medizinische
personal dran
insgesamt 21 millionen menschen dazu die
bewohner von altenheimen eine riesige
logistische herausforderung flugzeuge
und lkws sind unterwegs alleine diese
woche soll es bereits 3 millionen
impfungen geben
ich habe tränen in den augen aufregend
hier wird gerade geschichte geschrieben
angesichts von derzeit rund 200.000
neuinfektionen pro tag und vollen
intensivstationen appelliert der
gesundheitsminister an die zahlreichen
im skeptiker
im land amerikanische volk sollte wissen
dass diese impfstoffe sicher und
wirkungsvoll sind also wenn ihnen die
enten empfohlen wird und sie sie
bekommen können bitte lassen sie sich
unter 300.000 todesopfer hat co wird
bislang in den usa gefordert viele
hoffen dass der heutige tag die
langersehnte wende bringt und so viel
zum thema corona wir bleiben aber noch
einen moment in den usa
es ist eigentlich eine reine formalie
doch in diesem jahr schauen fehler mit
spannung auf die 538 wahlleute
die wählen heute nämlich offiziell den
künftigen präsidenten und der wird nach
den mehrheitsverhältnissen in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten joe biden heißen
sie nehmen ersten bundesstaaten wie hier
in nevada wurde bereits per
video-konferenz abgestimmt mit
landesweit 306 wahlleuten ist beides
mehrheit deutlich 270 stimmen sind für
einen wahlsieg erforderlich offiziell
wird das ergebnis erst am 6 januar
verkündet der neue vorsitzende der cdu
soll am 16 januar bei einem online
parteitag mit abschließender briefwahl
bestimmt werden
darauf hat sich heute der parteivorstand
verständigt außer ex unionsfraktionschef
friedrich merz wollen
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet und
der außenexperte norbert röttgen
parteichef werden
alle drei stellen sich in diesen minuten
in einem online format den fragen von
cdu mitgliedern
die regierung will beim ausbau von
öko-strom aufs tempo drücken darauf
haben sich jetzt cdu csu und spd
geeinigt demnach sollen gemeinden
finanziell profitieren wenn bei ihnen
windkraftanlagen entstehen und wer eine
solaranlage auf dem dach hat der staat
jetzt noch mehr geld wenn er den
produzierten strom selbst verbraucht die
reform tritt voraussichtlich zum ersten
januar in kraft
wohl kaum jemand sonst verstand sich auf
das mit jedes spionageromans so gut wie
john le carré vor seiner autorenkarriere
diente der brite selbst im geheimdienst
ihrer majestät jetzt ist er gestorben
le carré hieß eigentlich david cornwell
das pseudonym
er sich zu weil mitarbeiter des mi6
keine bücher unter ihrem richtigen namen
veröffentlichen durften seien wohl
bekanntester roman der spion der aus der
kälte kam spielt in berlin des kalten
kriegs und verkaufte sich rund 20
millionen mal
john le carré wurde 89 jahre alt jetzt
sind wir in dieser sendung beim sport
beziehen das bist du fußball champions
league auslosung fortuna war relativ
gnädig mit den vier deutschen vereinen
die aufgaben für bayern münchen und
borussia dortmund erscheinen lösbar
schwieriger könnte es allerdings im
achtelfinale für rb leipzig und borussia
mönchengladbach werden mitte februar
geht es los allein zwei der vier
deutschen teams treffen auf englische
klubs leipzig gegen liverpool sevilla im
duell mit dem bvb
lazio rom begrüßt die bayern und
gladbach spielt gegen manchester city
ist eine großartige mannschaft die über
jahre hinweg fantastisch
zusammengestellt wurde und trotzdem
versucht man natürlich als verein die
bussen in gladbach auch da hinzufahren
und seine chance zu nutzen auch wenn sie
klein zu sein scheint sie immer schön
auch in rom zu sein ist eine ganz
besondere start und wir wollen natürlich
ein besonderes highlight für uns
natürlich und auf rb leipzig wartet das
traditionsreiche liverpool zu dem
treffen zwei deutsche trainer
aufeinander
julia nagelsmann mit jürgen klopp und
der englische meister hatte die
champions league 2009 10 gewonnen es ist
eines von vier spannenden duellen der fc
sevilla wird also mitte februar die
erste große reifeprüfung für den neuen
bvb cheftrainer edin terzic der seine
spielphilosophie auf der heutigen
pressekonferenz in dortmund so beschrieb
fragt es einfach es gibt zwei arten wie
man ein fußballspiel gewinnen kann das
ist einmal wir versuchen ein tor weniger
zu kassieren als der gegner
ich bin eher dafür dass wir bereit dafür
sind ein tor mehr zu schießen als der
gegner ist einfach kurz zusammenzufassen
auf den punkt in der zwischenrunde der
europa league bekommt es bayer
leverkusen mit dem schweizer meister
young boys bern zu tun und hoffenheim
mit norwegens meister von 2009 10 fk
molde höchst emotional der 67 stine
weltcup sieg der amerikanerin micaela
chiffren mit ihrem triumph im
riesenslalom in courchevel zog sie mit
rekordhalter marcel hirscher aus
österreich gleich ein bittersüßer erfolg
ein ganz spezieller moment sagte sie
unter tränen
in gedenken an ihren tödlich
verunglückten vater das muss man auch
erstmal verkraften mit 25 soviel danke
christin weniger schnee jetzt denn kaum
winterlich und mit neuem regen geht es
beim wetter weiter mehr dazu gleich von
pest intelli dann das heute journal um
21.45 der kollege claus kleber hat
fragen an bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
und zwar sehr gerne
bis dann aber erst in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nach osten über
osteuropa und richtung russland hat sich
ein umfangreiches hoch etabliert da
community fse kaum gegen an und diese
tiefste die erreichen uns morgen
tagesverlauf und ziehen weiter nach
norden aber bereits in der nacht regnet
es im westen deutschlands und zwar vom
saarland über sauerland bis zur nordsee
hoch nach osten hin lockert es auch hier
zeigen sich mal die sterne sowie an den
alpen an der donau bildet sich nebel und
das bei temperaturen von null bis minus
3 grad im südosten und bis 8 grad ganz
im westen deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf zieht der regen bis etwa
zur mitte und zum nachmittag auch in den
osten und hier kann sich mal die sonne
zeigen genauso wie ganz im süden
ansonsten ist es häufig dicht bewölkt ja
und die temperaturen erreichen zwei grad
unter dem nebel an der donau und zwölf
grad ganz im westen und südwesten
deutschlands die nächsten tage am
mittwoch wird es relativ ruhig sein
nach nebel kommt auch mal die sonne
hervor bei vier bis elf grad und
donnerstag erreicht uns neuer regen aus
dem westen bei zwei bis elf freitag
ähnliche temperaturen ein schöner abend